>>Kathryn: My name is Kathryn,
I'm fourteen years old and I live
in Mount Pleasant, Michigan.
>>I don't really know what
originally put it into my head.
I'm not entirely sure, I think a
big part of it though was working
and going to car shows and
just seeing different things
that people had built.
>>It was kinda love at
first sight, you know.
It's just like this cool little
sporty car that you can just drive
around and it can just be
you and one other person.
And it's just-- I think
it's a cool little car.
>>When we first got the car home,
we put it into the back yard,
because I wanted to get
started right away, of course.
And so I was literally sitting there,
looking at the car and I'm like,
"Okay, where do I start?"
>>Jerry: This is the
hardest one to get.
Can you see where your
wear sleeve is down there?
>>Kathryn: Yeah, I can.
>>Jerry: Where the bottom
stroke of the piston is.
So you wanna be just
like just above that.
You got it, Pennello.
>>I got it.
>>All right.
>>We're good.
>>Dale: When we immerse ourself
in a big project or a problem set,
without even necessarily knowing
why or what the outcome is,
we have the opportunity
to learn new things
that are unlike any
other opportunity.
>>Jerry: Mm-hmm, look at that,
real close there on those two.
>>Dale: The project itself is
creating opportunities for her
to learn that she didn't
set out for that to happen.
>>Kathryn: So what I'm doing right
now is, I'm using telescope gauges
and micrometers to measure
the bore of the cylinder
in three different locations,
top, middle and bottom.
Then I'm also measuring the
diameter of the piston to make sure
that my tolerance levels are
where they're supposed to be.
>>Dale: Imagine if she kinda did
this as an exercise on paper,
or watched someone else do it.
The amount of real learning that
would happen would be minimal.
So it's really almost that diving
off the cliff and into something
that is really-- it's risky.
You know, she's spending
a lot of time on this,
and yet she's holding
it all together.
I think that's pretty amazing.
>>Kathryn: When I first
started school,
like all through elementary
school really,
I wasn't very good at math at all.
Like I had so many issues, like
we'd do flashcards every night
and I'd still just
completely not understand it.
And so like as I got older, it
started to be a problem, you know,
'cause you can't really pass
school without knowing math.
>>Then I started on this car, and
I could take lessons I'd learned
from the car and how I'd
used it mathematically to do
and solve the problems
in the classroom.
>>I'm not so sure it's solid.
>>Jerry: What's not solid?
>>Dale: The most basic level,
that you're learning to learn,
so you're becoming a better learner.
And your engagement
around learning is higher,
you're going to be more receptive
and open to new forms of learning,
even ones that don't
specially work for you.
>>Kathryn: That's way too small.
>>Some of the examples in my car
for math is like converting metric
to standard systems and just learning
how to measure and place parts
and to be able to understand how
much tolerance you need for it,
and so it helps to learn
your mathematical systems.
>>The forum, it's been a really
big part of this project,
because it's an online place
where you post comments,
almost like Facebook, and it's
called the Pennock's Fiero Forum
because it's pretty much
all based on Fieros.
>>Jerry: So you got this that
you weld in, and there's some
of your nice holes in
your frame rail finish.
>>Kathryn: You go in and there's
people working on all kinds
of different projects
to do with Fiero,
or just sharing feedback
or suggestions.
It's kind of like having
a bigger form
of a family really, on the forum.
>>So if I post just up onto my
thread and be like, "Hey, I'm stuck.
I need some help, SOS here."
And so, they'll be like, "All
right, what are you stuck on?
Let's see how I can help.
Here are some suggestions."
>>Dale: To be able to go
out and find those people,
no matter where they live,
who are working on cars
and say, "I've had that problem.
I know that transmission or this
replacement part that you buy
over here is not very good,
this one is a better one."
They're navigating a world of
living knowledge, all right.
It's not just book
knowledge, it's "real thing"
and how valuable is that?
>>Kathryn: I definitely think
about how school could be better
if they had more interactive
projects, because there's
so many kids who don't get to go on
and learn what they could really do,
because they don't have
these opportunities.
And so I think that if like schools
could offer more interactive,
more what you wanna do into
your classroom systems,
then a lot more kids would be willing
to learn, willing to go to school,
and actually having a good time
there, opposed to, "Oh my gosh,
I've got this next class
and I don't wanna go."
>>Dale: The Fiero is
Kathryn's car, it's her.
That object and her are aligned.
>>Kathryn: If I'm like having a rough
day at school or something, I'm like,
"Okay, in a few hours,
you're gonna be home.
You get to go to your shop and
you get to work and you just get
to forget everything else."